hello guys I'm Greg with me is Bree and
vlog on own I miss mommy
hit or miss movies is their channel you
have to go there see what the awesome
movie content is all about
yes mommy awesome leggings what they are
all about Wow
for flexible I am I was dancer where 100
was the USB song girl which means
basically USB cheerleader because people
wouldn't you say song girl are thinking
like I sing but no I'm in the white
uniform and I dance only girls that are
on the field that have the white uniform
on and go
speaking of erotic I boy no no I'm
excited now is coming out on Netflix
it's stars Aria from Game of Thrones
only down let's just see what this is
all about we don't know nothing we know
nothing
[Music]
- this wave of crime
everyone knows practices come by later
yes you were very lucky farm fragments
here and here missed the temporal lobe
will very satisfied this anything
unusual happens I want you to let me now
straight away I shot him with the god
particle
[Music]
oh damn I boy never been effective shut
up being a cargo full caught it had
clear running back through the eight
seconds that's what we're doing guys we
did not finish the trailer we stopped it
right away
now we gotta throw or so back into the
bathroom the other thing is that Tim
showed up in one man equally saying hey
they were there you talking about Lucy
talking about
[Music]
sort of vigilante function the shine
take on the gun
[Music]
Yacouba goggle Vanguard family turns up
when oh yes
longer than will work down
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
special kid special kid
it was so confused
were you confused about he's a vigilante
now ok they got shot in the head I guess
some fragments of whatever electronic
devices got planted in his brain yeah ok
now you can control everything now he
has you know when I find that it's hard
for me
maybe for you to you can let us know in
the comments they'll bring up words dirt
while you're watching telling you
something about a movie and I just don't
read those because I'm not focused on
like reading and remembering what I just
read so they'll give you like part of a
sentence alright and the rest of the
sentence yeah and I already missed the
first part they're like oh [ __ ] nothing
gotta go happen that happens well this
is a really interesting plot it could
work okay I think it could work I think
if you read the synopsis on IMDB out
loud I might understand what's happening
better
hey bran so after an accident this calm
guys this British kid wakes from a coma
he gets in a coma after a gunshot to
discover that fragments of his a
smartphone have been embedded in his
head Oh cuz he was on the floor yeah
when they shot him so it's like sooner
or like every accident happened though
and worse and worse that returning to
normal feelin teenage life is impossible
because he has developed a strange set
of superpower okay I feel like this
would be a cool show yes then an hour
and a half a movie just for an hour and
a half my concern is that it seems like
it might go down conventional route this
looks like a conventional kind of like
way on superhero film freak accident a
series yeah would prefer a miniseries of
anything conventional right happened he
loves a girl get some old bad guy bad
guy kidnap you're looking for her yeah
though it seemed like yeah I don't know
why they're doing that because she's bad
maybe she's bad I mean the main reason I
want the puppet master
yeah whales and already guys I was maybe
gonna watch this man was amazing
Williams in it and I'm like oh she's
just a girl who's a hero love it I like
the concept I like the idea of this guy
developing superpowers I mean hey if
this film is very effective I feel like
people are gonna actually try to shoot
me in the alley with my eyebrows are
very unfortunate a lot of people haven't
try it
don't try it was possible how cool would
that be really just have to wait for
someone else to try it and we'll find
out I just wonder how justified some of
the powers will be though like when he
goes into that one guy and sees like
this skeletal outlay of his calf or me
or whatever he kicks them like I don't
understand how the electronic advices it
able to do Mike Kennedy's like x-ray
vision I'm more likely to understand
something like that movie Lucie where
it's like that's about that kind of yeah
oh you move which is kind of an odd and
this I think total or do that I don't
know maybe they just were like yeah
Lucy's a good name yeah all of that I
mean I like the first half of the
trailer more it was when I started
getting all vigilante and then really
nine cliche of how was gonna play out
where I started losing some interest
because I like that it feels really dark
I feel like this could be really gritty
I feel like that's what we can make it
stand out instead of going some pg-13
route I thought you can make this one
feel different than a lot of these super
hero vigilante accidental stories by
making it more violent and more sinister
in some ways with the lights going on at
the end did you think of this is what I
thought of immediately Fight Club yeah
okay I didn't figure out I wasn't the
only one told it looks like exactly I
see the first half seemed like it had
like some originality in there towards a
lot how much around like this seems very
much all inspired now it doesn't lacking
something but I like the title i boy hi
boy yeah it's clever
whoever smartphone smartphone in his
brain I boy did has got to be a way
where we can make this happen
all by the I'll buy the gun you know
where the phone your phone will use your
phone I know you're come on
Antonia I can finally get Kristian
harloff number I don't have his number
[Music]
but I feel like you know we're slowly
becoming nice they're like oh yeah like
Google glass no need it's not worry
everybody do this oh I think we're good
I know I think I'd probably watch I was
coming to Netflix I might Emmy yeah the
Netflix original and you could trust
Netflix in the content they deliver like
ridiculous 6 to do over you know Cena no
but I saw the little prince and they
really like this isn't so it does that
enough thousand applique guys that's it
for today if she needed the channel
subscribe as how you salute like this
know every every military person has
brain damage from hitting her head too
hard I waited there and hit or miss
movies had some awesome awesome content
on there you can follow her on Twitter
at miss movies seriously she deserves
way more followers
I created the show six degrees of
feature film I created YouTube I
reiterated films every yeah there's
gonna be a sound she's so popular she
won't be able to come on my channel
watch out that walk out well that's all
law of attraction based if you doubt
that and it's never gonna happen I would
love it if we can get to a point our
lives on Mike hey can you come on you're
like I'm sorry I can't Neville is this
[ __ ] you how did you get my number I
don't hang out I would never do that
I've no matter how bright on YouTube no
I want that try to you you'll be just as
coffee and egotistical as all them as
all them I mean you know Mark Ellis
total douchebag you're a lie
Kristian harloff narcissistic [ __ ]
Jeremy John's he shat on the floor a
Collider
to prove that I'm number one girl water
now oh my goodness
that July look Vic dude guy just works
out that's mine